Dr richard,
higher studies the neural basis of human
intelligence and cognition.
He works with neuroimaging technologies
to study individual differences in
mental ability.
He received his phd in psychology from
the Johns Hopkins University in Nineteen
75 and has since held appointments in
the intramural research program at the
National Institute of Mental Health and
the medical school at Brown University
and the University of California at
Irvine Irvine.
He has served on the editorial board or
three journals,
neuro,
image intelligence and psychiatry
research.
He also served as guest editor for a
special issue on brain imaging research
for the journal intelligence.
He provides neuroscience consultation,
do university research groups,
corporations,
foundations,
and educational and legal professionals.
He's a popular lecturer and has appeared
in numerous media outlets in 2012.
His research was featured on Nova
science now and he received the
distinguished contributor award for the
International Society for intelligence
research.
In 2013.
The teaching company invited Richard to
create an 18 lecture course called the
intelligent rate.
So welcome to Dr Richard.
Higher today and we're going to talk
about the most controversy of all
topics.
I would say in social science,
uh,
strangely enough intelligence,
so maybe we could start with a little
bit of historical information.
I would like to know how you got
interested in Iq research or
intelligence research,
let's say.
And,
and,
and so let's start with that and then we
can start diving.
Diving into the nitty gritty.
Well,
really it started in graduate school at
Hopkins when I really became most
interested in personality research and I
started out studying individual
differences in personality,
but just by happenstance,
the year I started graduate school in
Nineteen 71 was the year one of the
professors there,
Julian Stanley was study up
mathematically precocious youth and I
was one of the proctors at the very
first challenge search for
mathematically precocious kids.
And I wrote my first couple of papers as
book chapters in books that Stanley was
editing about this project.
And I saw these,
these kids age 10,
11,
12 when we're scoring higher on sat
math,
then hopkins freshmen.
And the question was how does this
happen?
Where does this come from?
So now it's kind of my earliest interest
and in graduate school,
although I really completed my
dissertation on personality,
uh,
I took my first job at the National
Institute of Mental Health in the
intramural research program in the
laboratory and psychology and
psychopathology,
which at the time the lab director was
David Rosenthal who had just finished
the Denmark adoption studies of
schizophrenia.
Right.
And here is where I learned about
genetics.
My office was next door to a fellow
named Monte bucks bond who was doing it
both for initial search,
very interested in that.
And so my,
my early interest in,
in,
in individual differences slowly morphed
into an interest in individual
differences in intelligence and add nim
age.
They were just going through a
transition from kind of a
psychoanalytic,
a orientation to a neuro science
orientation and I was kind of caught up
in that.
And so that's the origin of my interest
in the brain in technologies to make
brain measurements and relate that to
individual differences.
Okay,
great.
Okay.
Now you just wrote a book too,
and the neuroscience of intelligence can
be a university press.
And so when did that come out?
That came out really just about six
months ago,
so it came out I think in December of
2016,
but they tell me for publishing reasons,
they call it a 2017 publication.
While I'm.
Part of the reason I was so excited to
talk to you is that are done a very
large amount of research,
especially not so much practical lab
research,
but investigation into the structure of
intelligence and into its measurement.
We designed back in [inaudible] 93 with
a student of mine,
Daniel Higgins.
We designed,
well,
it was probably the first online battery
purporting to measure the cognitive
abilities associated with dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex.
Right?
So I had the highest order cognitive
functions in the brain and we found,
much to our chagrin I would say,
and this was very painful discovery,
that a lot of what we have been thinking
about as potentially separable
neuro-psychological functions were
pretty easily collapsible,
collapsible into good old general
intelligence.
You know,
that killer is central factor that seems
to cognitive abilities.
And so it was quite a shock,
especially because the neuro
psychologists have the time and they
still do this,
uh,
are,
are as assiduous in investigators of the
psychometric intelligence literature is
they should be intent to underestimate
the central power of that in that
initial factor.
So anyways,
I'm really interested into intelligence
research partly from a practical
perspective too,
because the industrial organizational
psychology literature is crystal clear
for complex jobs.
The best predictor of longterm success
is intelligence and it's a predictor
that's probably
say imagine you give it an r of point
four to point five,
which is pretty decent.
So let's say 25 percent of the variance,
the next best predictor is
conscientiousness and it's pushing it's
limit at mopping up 10 percent of the
variability in longterm performance.
So Iq,
it's a killer man.
And if we,
I make sure my students assess
intelligence with everything they do and
it always ends up being a major
predictor of things that you wouldn't
even expect.
Like disgust sensitivity for example.
So your disgust sensitivity is higher if
you have a lower Iq,
the g factor is powerful.
You just said something though that I
want to just make a distinction about
you.
We're talking about the g factor and
then you kind of called it Iq.
This is very common in everyday language
to talk about intelligence Iq in what we
call the g factor as one thing and it
really isn't.
So an Iq score is a good estimate of the
g factor also includes other aspects of
intelligence and intelligence in itself,
although as a broad term is only a part
of the universe of mental abilities,
so if you are very good at calculating
on what day?
January fifth was in the year,
15,
20.
That's a mental ability that some people
have.
It doesn't mean you're smart,
right?
With autistic survived so often and that
they're often but
sufficiently often they have these
amazing calculus calculation abilities
for example,
that don't seem to be manifest in a
spectacularly high overall intelligence.
Well,
so what do you.
What do you want to tell us about?
You want to start with the book and and
walk us through it.
Well,
you know that's interesting because the
book is kind of a culmination of things.
I've learned mostly from my neuroimaging
work on intelligence and it kind of came
as a surprise,
is the first book I've ever written.
I'm now retired actually from academia,
never wrote a book while I was in
academia is writing journal papers,
uh,
but Cambridge University press called
and they have this series of
fundamentals of neuroscience and they
wanted to include intelligence and I
regarded that as a major step because
intelligence research really has been
relegated almost to a,
the peripheral of mainstream psychology
politically to say the least.
Yeah.
And you know,
the switch happened overnight from being
in the mainstream to being really
peripheral in about 1969 before 1969.
Uh,
almost everyone who was interested in
education was concerned about the
achievement gaps and they felt
universally that once you equalized
educational opportunities,
those achievement gaps would disappear.
Yeah.
That was the head start head start.
Even before headstart,
headstart came to head start,
but even before headstart,
there were all these demonstration
projects.
That was one of the miracle in
Milwaukee.
And there were all these things that
showed that if you really intervened in
early childhood education.
Yep,
which at that time was called
compensatory education.
The early childhood education term came
much later,
but this idea of compensatory education
really took off and then in 1969,
the harvard educational review asked one
of the foremost educational
psychologist,
Arthur Jensen to write a review of the
progress and this article in 1969 is
become infamous.
The opening sentence was essentially
we've tried compensatory education and
it has failed,
and then he had 100 pages of detailed
statistical analysis of why there were
no.
You couldn't demonstrate an increase in
Iq score and any of these programs now
headstart had had just begun.
So headstart wasn't included.
Yeah,
but I,
you know,
I reviewed the literature on headstart
to extensively and basically what
happened was that the.
So that was for those viewers who don't
know,
headstart was a nationwide attempt to,
to add additional education to the lives
of disadvantaged kids especially,
you know,
at the preschool level.
And basically what happened was that
they actually did show improvements in
academic achievement initially.
So in grade one and grade two,
they were performing above their peers.
But then the difference in improvement,
the difference in performance started to
decrease and then my grade grade five,
grade six,
that differences in disappeared
completely,
so there was no evidence whatsoever of
that,
of that either have a stable one time,
longterm gain in cognitive ability or
what people were really hoping was that
if you intervene early enough you get
something that would sort of,
Paul would turn into a positive feedback
loop and the gains would actually
advance across time.
And what ended up happening with the
headstart research basically was the
conclusion that it produced no cognitive
improvements whatsoever.
Although more kids who went through
headstart,
I'm graduated from high school,
fewer than were delinquent,
more of them,
fewer of them became pregnant teenage in
the teenage years and more of them went
to colleges,
but that seemed to be because they were
better socialized not because they were
in any way.
It had been made smarter.
So that was a really tremendous
disappointment because it was a
bipartisan attempt to come to grips with
the fundamental issues that sort of beat
deviled structural poverty in the United
States.
No one was happy about that outcome.
I can tell you,
jetson published his article.
He also said that since I cue increases
seemed not to be coming from these
intense environmental interventions,
we should consider the possibility that
these differences have a genetic
component and that really began the
incendiary descent of intelligent search
to the periphery,
to the reaction against that was
universal.
Um,
because it implied inferiority.
If you building teams for Icu,
it's also something that's universally
hated,
but on both sides of the political
spectrum,
because on the liberal end,
you know,
the idea fundamentally is this,
that everybody's the same and that if
you,
if you distribute educational resources
property than everyone can succeed.
And so that didn't work out so well for
liberals.
And then on the conservative side,
the idea is,
well,
if you could just get off your lazy ass
and get a job,
there is a job for you out there.
And the truth of the matter is,
you know,
you can tell me what you think about
this,
but this was a statistic that just
absolutely shocked and staggered me when
I went through the Intel intelligence
literature.
So you know,
it is illegal in the United States to
induct anybody who has an Iq of less
than 83 and the reason for that is you
know that the American armed forces have
been conducting intelligence research
for like more than 100 years and that
was partly because they needed a way of
sorting people rapidly during times of
military expansion during war time.
But it was also because Iq tests and
especially in the early part of the 20th
century were used to identify,
let's say the deserving poor who could
really benefit from additional
educational attainment and advancement
and the unit and the military was hoping
to identify people from lower class
strata that can be streamed into say,
officer training programs and so forth
or,
or even skills training programs to to
move people from the underclass into at
least the working class and maybe above.
So they had a bloody stake in this man.
They wanted to find people,
they wanted to sort them properly and
they wanted to do social good when they
weren't just trying to win a war,
let's say.
Which often also is a social good.
But what happened was that by,
I don't remember when this legislation
was introduced,
but it wasn't,
it was in the later part of the 20th
century,
but there are basic finding,
was that by say the 19 eighties,
they had determined that if you had an
Iq of less than 83,
there was not a damn thing that the unit
that the army could do,
the armed forces could do to transform
you into someone who could do something
that was more productive than
nonproductive.
And the terrible thing about that is
that it's about 10 percent of the
population.
And so they look at a statistic like
that and you think,
oh my God,
you've got this,
this,
this enterprise,
this massive enterprise that's
chronically hungry for people to write.
It's always,
they're always looking for people.
They're really oriented towards taking
people from the underclass and lower
working class and pushing them up the
societal strata and during war time
there actually desperate to bring in
recruits,
period.
And their conclusion is the 10 percent
of the population can't be trained to do
anything.
Anything sufficiently useful to make
them militarily operable.
It's just,
I just read that my jaw just dropped.
It's like,
oh yeah.
In the United States we have about 330
million people and because of the
distribution,
the relatively normal distribution of Iq
scores,
about 16 percent.
Have I accuse of 85 or means they're not
going to graduate school?
No.
It means that from,
from what I've read practically,
it means the wonder this company has
actually done a really.
They have a nice Iq tents from the
commercial perspective,
you know,
it's actually psychometrically valid and
they've linked Iq levels to a job.
Specifically the job categories.
I know not a lot.
I was going to say they're not only not
going to graduate school,
they're not going to find a a stable job
that pays a livable wage.
Yeah.
Especially given that so many of the
service jobs now require fair,
high degree of computational savvy or a
built.
No,
I'm not computation,
but ability to interact with complex
computational technology typical till
ladder at a checkout market or or the
till at a Mcdonald's because Mcdonald's
is actually very complicated.
Is often far beyond the ability of
people who are on the low end of the
intelligence distribution and they
claimed,
I think it was wonderlic,
although it might know it might've been.
It might've been hunt.
That's his name.
They.
He's a ICU researcher.
Is it earl haunts?
I think possibly what he claimed that if
you have an Iq of below 90 it,
it's,
it's difficult.
It's difficult for you to read well
enough to translate what you're reading
into action,
so you can't actually read instructions
and follow them.
You don't have that level of literacy.
Yeah.
I was going to say that in,
in the United States,
this bottom 16 percent translates into
51 million people,
including $13 million children who are
in school.
This is a very difficult problem now.
I knew earl passed away when I knew him
pretty well.
He also would say that there is this,
a cognitive segregation in society.
This is a point that Charles Murray
makes and they often ask,
uh,
you know,
when's the last time you had someone
over for dinner who wasn't a college
Grad?
Well,
that was something that Marie and her
starting wrote about in their book the
bell curve,
which really struck me because I read
that book twice,
unlike most of the people criticized it
and you know,
we're one of the things that they
pointed out in there,
it was,
look,
the typically a typical educated person
thinks that someone isn't very bright if
they have an Iq of 150.
So how'd you at graduate level,
Phd Level Research Institutions,
right?
Because 115,
there's,
there's as many people at 150 and above
as there are at 85 and below.
And so it's a minority of the population
and that's the top 15 percent.
And you know,
that's,
that's the dollar undergraduate,
right?
So people have.
See I'm a clinical psychologist and I've
dealt with people who had,
I ranges in the low eighties and tried
to find them jobs and tried to train
them.
And I have some real knowledge about the
stunning gap between people at the low
end of the ICU distribution in the high
end.
And it's,
it's no bloody wonder.
People hate Iq research and intelligence
research because it reveals a set of
seriously
a dismal
facts about the incredible range of
ability among human beings.
Well,
yes,
this is true.
And moreover I would add to this that
people in universities,
professors and graduate students have a
hard time understanding what the,
what everyday life is like.
If you have an Iq of 84,
85 and we're making your way,
you're living independently.
You were making your way in the world
five.
It is a challenge.
I mean,
just barely begins to describe it.
I had a,
I had a client who,
he probably had an Iq of under 80 and
nonverbal portion of it anyways,
and um,
he was indistinguishable and physical
appearance from,
from let's say,
I hate to use the frame normal person,
but there's nothing more that marked him
out about particularly intellectually
impaired,
you know.
And uh,
I tried at one point,
this was so,
so telling to me,
I got him an inch,
a volunteer job,
which by the way is very difficult.
It's harder to get a volunteer job in a
real job because you have to do police
screening and all sorts of things and
the selection process is just as
extreme,
but I eventually ended up getting a job
at a bike store,
bike slash bookstore,
and at that place couldn't hold him once
the subsidy program had expired and then
I him a job at a charity and his job was
to fold letters into three so that they
can be put into envelopes.
Well,
that sounds easy except that he also had
a bit of a motor tremor and you know,
it took me about 30 hours to train him
to fold up a piece of paper with
sufficient precision so that it can be
put in an envelope rapidly so that the
envelope wasn't so mangled that it would
get stuck in the automatic sorting
machine.
And another is high performance demands
on him too.
He had to whip through those letters
pretty quickly and then sometimes the
letters would have a photograph
appendant to them that was stapled on
and they weren't always stapled on in
the same place.
So then he had to calculate how to fold
the paper over the photograph without
bending the photograph in precise third
so that would still fit in the envelope.
And then he had to separate the French
letters from the English letters and
associate them with the proper
envelopes.
And like that level of complexity just
did him in it.
Number one.
So
let me say two things.
One is I hope common sense and the other
is pretty provocative.
The common sense things.
We had to be very careful when we have
these discussions not to devalue the
human dignity of people who are in the
upper end of the distribution.
And if there's one criticism that is
fair is sometimes in these conversations
it sounds like we're devaluing people at
the lower end of the distribution and we
have to be very careful that we don't do
that.
A human life has dignity and Iq is not
the most important thing that defines
human beings even
associated with wisdom.
It's not necessarily associated with
truth or with courage or with many
virtues that that are how great your
identity at all with being likable or on
the psychometric psychometric
relationship between intelligence and
conscientiousness is zero.
Right.
I think we have to make that point.
Yes,
I agree.
I'm trying to make the point about how
difficult it is for people who are on
the low end of the cognitive spectrum to
survive in an increasingly complex,
cognitively sophisticated environment.
Right.
Your obs are just disappearing.
Yes,
absolutely.
Now let's ask the question.
Is there anything that could be done
about that?
Well,
Western society has tried very hard with
a number of environmental
environmentally based interventions,
early childhood education.
By the way that you said the.
The literature in organizational
psychology is very clear.
The literature is equally clear in
educational psychology.
Oh yeah.
Well,
the relationship between Iq and learning
is more powerful than the relationship
between Iq job performance,
that that's right.
Which is kind of common sense or matches
are common sense,
but you know,
if you put a bunch of variables into a
regression equation to predict academic
achievement and you have all these
school quality variables and teacher
quality variables and cognitive
variables of the students and what you
find is that teacher variables and the
quality of the school variables together
barely account for 10 percent.
I know,
I know.
It's terrible.
Talk to the guy who ran it,
admissions at Harvard.
I taught at Harvard for a while.
His name was dean with law and he a
really smart guy.
I really liked the and you know,
he was,
let's say he was on the right side of
the human race and he was really trying
to figure out how to run the admissions
policy at Harvard so that it did the
best for everyone concerned.
And he had run an interesting series of
analysis that I don't believe he ever
published.
And one of them was um,
well let's say you segregate the Harvard
population into the relatively low Iq
kids.
So maybe they only have an Iq of 130,
you know,
and the relatively high Iq kids who were
pushing up towards two,
160.
So you are two competing hypotheses
there.
One would be that the lower Iq kids come
to Harvard,
this remarkable environment,
and they and they,
and,
and they,
they thrive because of the high
educational quality so well that they
close the gap between them and the one
60 kids.
And that's just completely,
completely wrong.
What happens is you put both those
groups,
they're both very,
very highly selected,
but some,
you know,
in this sort of superman rage
intellectually,
what happens is the gap just gets bigger
and bigger as they progress through
university.
And it's a dreaded example of that,
uh,
matthew principle that the economists
talk about,
which is no to those who have more will
be given.
And from those who have nothing,
everything will be taken.
It's very,
very.
It's no wonder people disliked this
research.
It's so,
it's so anti egalitarianism and it's
essential and it's essential structure.
Well,
what I wanted to make a second point
that I said would be provocative if you
want to do something about this.
Uh,
you know,
we tried a bunch of interventions,
earnest,
well funded,
long term interventions don't seem to
work,
but neuro science has been excluded from
discussions about what to do about this.
And I believe that neuroscience progress
in neuroscience research has the
potential to really dramatically
increase the g factor.
Well,
that's an optimistic statement.
So I'm sure looking forward to some
support for that one.
It's optimistic and reversal and you
know,
just as a thought experiment,
and I can tell you why I believe this is
possible.
What will first,
before I tell you the thought
experiment,
the reason I'm optimistic is that it is
because of the high heritability of the
g factor.
That means your genes are involved.
Gene's work through biology,
even if the environment interacts with
that.
But basically you have a neuro
biological system.
It's complex,
but as you begin to understand it,
you can tweak it.
This is what all medicine is doing now.
They're trying to understand the neural
biology slash genetic basis of our
health and our diseases.
Why so they can fix it.
When you go to the doctor,
you're going because you were biology is
broken and you love your biology fixed.
Well,
let's think about the brain now.
No one conceptualized as low Iq as a
disease and it's a little dangerous,
but to the extent to which low Iq has
the genetic input or genetic influence,
that's the extent to which you might be
able to to find out how that works,
how that,
what that system is,
and then figure out how to tweak that
system to increase Iq.
It's not science fiction.
I mean that's.
That's a plausible sequence of events.
What the problem is,
it's a very complex sequence,
but I also think it's a finite set of
problems,
not an infinite set of problems.
So the physicists,
physicists configure out what happened
during the first nanoseconds of the big
bang.
We can certainly figure out what the
neural biology of intellect and how to
tweak it.
So I think that's possible.
So now let's,
let's do a thought experiment.
Let's imagine there's an icu pill and I
mean that metaphorically not really
appealing.
You could take like putting a floor,
but like having fluoridated water just
kind of raises the dental health of
everybody would be nice if we had that
for Iq,
but just to imagine what it would be
like if we shifted the distribution of
Iq 15 points into the high end so that
now the average Iq,
I understand how it was computed and
norming and everything,
but the point is that no one would have
an Iq less than 100.
Right.
What would the world be like if everyone
could reason sufficiently to get a
reasonable job?
Well,
that's a good question.
I mean,
the,
the uh,
what would you call the perverse part of
me as funny?
I was just talking to one of my graduate
students.
We'd be looking at the determinants of
male attractiveness by the personality
of female viewers.
Okay.
And so what we found is that there are
some personality effects.
So I'm extroverted,
enthusiastic women tend to rate men
generally speaking as more attractive
than introvert or introverted,
less enthusiastic women.
And um,
and so,
so there are some just straight
personality effects,
but the biggest effect by far we found
list the proclivity of,
of women in general to rape men as less
attractive as the women's Iq increased.
And so the other thing that we don't
know is what price we pay for,
for accelerated Iq from a,
from a broader perspective,
you know,
because I know that there is some
evidence,
and you can tell me what you think about
this because I know that there's
reasonable evidence that the average Iq
of the Ashkenazi Jewish population is
about 15 points higher than the standard
population,
which is kind of makes it a thought
experiment.
It's an experiment,
real life experiment.
It's equivalent to the one that you laid
out.
But aszkenazy Jews also tend to suffer
from a host of neurological diseases
that seem to be associated with
increased neuroplasticity.
And so to me it's often,
it's often hard to gain on one front
without losing on another.
You know,
I mean that's the evolutionary conundrum
obviously,
but we call that the social justice
theory.
If you started one thing,
you have to be bad and everything else
that kind of balanced it out,
probably speaking,
you do pay a price for your,
for your exceptionalism,
you know that.
That's true because,
you know,
the,
uh,
the Julian Stanley studies or the math
coaches,
kids essentially found not only were
they smart,
but they were more mature than their age
peers.
Better looking,
they were color.
They were physically more fit.
I mean,
it was kind of the anti social.
I know that's terrible.
Well,
I mean it's just,
that also might be true because one of
the things that can interfere with Iq is
poor health and poor nutritional quality
and all of that.
I mean,
it doesn't look like it's that easy to
increase Iq,
but it looks like it's pretty easy to
decrease it.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I think that those,
those things have to be pretty extreme.
Yeah.
They have an effect and those effects
may not be permanent.
Actually,
some studies of deprivation of people
who suffer suffered deprivation during
the second world war that suggests that
Lowe's really severe,
uh,
deprivations didn't have lasting effects
on,
you know,
well,
people were pretty tough,
so I'm inclined to agree with that.
So,
so have you seen any animal experiment,
experimental work that you regard as
compelling that shows something like the
transformation of,
of animal cognition into our,
into something that's,
it's,
it's higher order that you regard as
compelling?
Not sure what you mean,
but there are certainly animal that
shows you extract the g factor from
cognitive tests given to various
animals.
Right?
So what I was wondering is has there
been any evidence that you regard as
credible showing at that could be that
that say so called animal g factor
extracted in the same.
We should tell our readers to.
The way you extract the g factor,
I'm going to say it very,
very rapidly,
is imagine you take a randomly set,
randomly selected set of 200 questions
that require abstraction of one form or
another to solve.
And then can
you give those 200 questions to 100
people?
And you sum the scores and you rank
order them.
You get something that's roughly
equivalent there to a g factor.
It's roughly that.
So just say it a little bit differently.
Just forever is on the same page.
If you think of all the different mental
abilities and you devise a test for each
one of them and you gave this test where
a lot of people across the range of
ability,
what you'll find is the scores on all
those tests are positively correlated
with each other,
suggesting that all tests have mental
ability,
have something in common that's a great
name.
This g factor,
this general ability to reason and some
individual tests have more Gillotti men,
other individual tests and tests of
abstract reasoning tend to be highly
guy.
He said to you,
repeat the following numbers back to me.
Three,
seven,
two,
one,
six,
five.
That's not a very highly loaded mental
ability to be able to do that.
But if I gave you a streamline that and
said,
repeat them to me backwards,
that becomes a g loaded ability because
the transformation.
Well,
the other thing to say about that too is
that a positive relationship between
that stems multiple assessments that you
described is actually quite high.
Right?
That's the thing is that that general
factor not only exists across domains of
cognitive ability,
but it tends to account for a
substantial amount of the,
have the ability in each of those
domains,
right?
It's kind of like Regina is kind of like
a black hole for intelligence research
and everything keeps falling into it.
So that's an interesting way to put it
because now we have these,
uh,
junior association studies that are
finding these bits of DNA that are
related to either latent factor of
intelligence,
which is the g factor or two what they
call educational attainment variable.
So school attainment is so highly
correlated with Iq and that is
essentially the same thing.
So we're really moving.
When I was in graduate school,
the question was,
is there a genetic component to
intelligence or not?
This kind of DNA analysis,
trying to find bits of DNA that are
going to be related to what we call a
intelligence or Iq testing or,
or,
or the g factor,
and they seem to exist.
There seems to be hundreds of them.
A tiny effect,
uh,
which will make the ultimate story are
extremely complicated.
But as I said before,
I think it's a finite set of problems
right at the end of that sequence of
solving those problems.
I think there's a good chance we'll know
how to increase Iq and I think it's a
good thing to be able to do that.
You know,
I had said publicly that more
intelligence is better than less.
Sometimes I get criticized because that
implies that people with less
intelligence aren't as worthwhile.
That's why I want to be very careful
that I don't believe that is more of the
accurate way of thinking about it and in
a narrow range of possibilities and
opportunities.
That's right.
And in my view,
my political biases there for
governments have a moral responsibility
to help those people.
And,
and,
uh,
a lot of government programs are,
aren't going to do it because your job
training requires a certain level of uh,
and,
and so
Iq clients,
they used to go to the government
agencies that were designed to help
people find employment and you know,
the typical response was,
well just go home and type up your CV
and distributed.
It's like a,
you're just like,
can't use a computer.
I can't type,
I don't know what to CV is,
it's like it's,
it's a nonstarter and all three
councils,
right?
That's right.
So in the United States there are 51
million people with iqs under 85 and
there were about 43 million people
living in poverty.
Do you think those Venn diagrams
intersect?
Well,
we should also be clear about that
because it is so politically suspect is
that it's not like it's,
it's,
it's self evident that people who have
less cognitive capability are likely to
end up poor because there a serious
complex problems in life that beset them
that they have a difficult time dealing
with and they can't learn as quickly.
And so the relationship between poverty
and intelligence is self evident if
you're willing to think it through for
any length of time.
It doesn't mean that everybody who's
rich that is.
It doesn't mean that everyone who is
rich is smart and it doesn't mean that
everyone who is poor is stupid,
what it took to be blunt.
But what it mean is that if you're
intelligent,
you're much more likely to become
financially successful.
And I think it was the Hertenstein
Herrnstein and Murray.
I think the calculations back in the
bell curve that indicated that if you
imagined that you could,
you were a fairy godmother and you have
your newborn grandchild in front of you
and you can grant them three standard
deviations above the mean in terms of
wealth at birth.
Or you can grant them three standard
deviations above the mean in terms of Iq
at birth.
And then you wanted to determine which
would work better for them by the time
they were 40.
And the answer to that was quite clear
is that Iq trump's wealth,
terrific.
If it's related to predict a positive
future.
So that's why I'm so interested in the
concept of increasing Iq or increasing
the g factor,
not just the Iq score,
but really what Andre this reasoning
ability.
So you know,
some people have tried to teach college
students critical thinking.
I think that's a good thing if you can
think critically so much the better.
Exactly.
You know,
and you know,
it may sound to your listeners,
I just want to take a moment out here.
It may sound to your listeners like here
are these two guys pontificating about
what it's like to be smart,
not so smart.
I mean the point of this,
the point of neuroscience research,
all intelligence and what I hope to
achieve by writing the book was to show
that that the genetic aspects are not
deterministic.
It's the opposite.
So probabilistic,
so the extent to which something like
intelligence is genetic in my view,
is the extent to which we'll learn how
to change it for the better.
Well that's definitely.
Yeah,
because people do tend to think about a
biological factors as deterministic in
that that's a mistake because they can
be shifted.
So.
So
with regards to the animal study,
so you know,
you pointed out that you can,
you can come up with an Iq like estimate
for say a rat and have you seen anything
that indicates I don't care how it's
done through training or or or
neurochemically or or or by promoting
brain function in different ways.
However you might do it.
That's actually indicated to you that
there is a way of biologically enhancing
the general cognitive ability.
Even have an animal has anything
credible just by breeding mice in a maze
faster than other mice.
Together you get mice.
It seemed to be able to learn how to run
a maze faster,
but that's work from the 19 eighties or
review this in the book.
There are some interesting technologies
that have been developed where you can
turn parts of a rat brain on and off at
will and see what happens.
This is not yet been applied as far as I
know to learning,
but interestingly there are human
studies underway with things like that.
A trans cranial magnetic stimulation and
electrical
ways to low voltage ways to stimulate
parts of the brain.
And there are some interesting
experiments now being done with humans
to see if you can improve learning or
reasoning ability benefactor,
I edit this journal,
the following colleges,
which is kind of a prime spot for
intelligence researchers to publish on
all aspects of intelligence and we're
just starting to put together a special
issue on human experiments to increase
reasoning ability using these,
these,
uh,
techniques of stimulating the brain.
You've seen some positive things with
regards to low level electrical
stimulation because that's also been
used.
It's more,
it's more anecdotal,
but there's a bit of research being used
to treat depression,
for example.
That's right.
And I do cover in the book the studies
that were published up until the time I
wrote the book and caution people that
they hadn't been replicated yet.
Right,
right,
right.
But we're on the way.
I mean,
this is,
this is an evolving area that's going to
be very exciting.
I mean,
if students are listening to this
podcast and we're thinking about
neuroscience or psychology,
this kind of experiment is,
is,
is really a new phase of intelligence
research where you can do experiments on
human beings that are completely
ethical,
um,
and relatively non intrusive,
uh,
and this is really going to change
everything because it will shift
intelligence research firm,
basically psychometric correlations past
what neuro imaging has done,
which,
which really moved it away from just
cycle metrics and then correlating
psychometric scores with measurable
aspects of the brain like coast
metabolic function or the amount of gray
matter or white matter or the number of
white matter fibers.
I mean,
we're all these fabulous connections,
right?
Was this new thing I got in early on
that things.
But that phase is now moving into this
new phase of actually stimulating the
brain to improve learning and memory and
reasoning and all the while doing it
with neuroimaging.
Right?
See what happens and adding DNA to it.
I mean,
come on now.
This is a great time.
Great.
Entering the research in this area,
right?
Right.
Well,
there's some optimism on the rise.
I looked for a
because I've been very interested in
improving human performance,
measuring it and improving it and so I
looked and and doing that also in
conjunction with businesses because I
like things to have a practical end and
you know,
I looked to find out what the research
indicated with regards to improvement of
intelligence and mostly what I found was
not so much improvement as conservation
is that if you exercise both aerobically
and and with weightlifting,
that that can help you maintain your
fluid intelligence across for longer
across your lifespan because it tends to
decline rather precipitously as you age,
which is one of the more dismal things
that you also discovered with Iq
research and starts to decline when
you're in your early twenties and it's
kind of a linear downhill all the way
along.
But exercise really helps
it's preservation,
which is pretty important that my
participation is a big deal man.
But enhancement would be good,
but you know this thing about an icu
pill coming up with a way to manipulate
your bio on the neurobiology of your
brain regarding intellect.
If there's a breakthrough in this,
it will come either from Alzheimer's
research,
more hormonal aging research,
trying to prevent the slow decline of
your mental faculties as you age,
especially fluid intelligence,
right?
Uh,
or trying to reverse the ravages of
Alzheimer's disease.
These are neurochemical problems right
now.
Tightly,
tightly linked to,
oh,
this is another thing we can talk about
because so,
um,
I know that there are certain biological
markers that Iq is loosely associated
with,
so you know,
it's fragmented.
It predicts in a fragmentary matters.
So I know that even something as simple
as simple reaction time,
how fast you can push a button when the
light comes on is correlated with Iq,
with fluid intelligence at about point
two,
and I'm having a bigger head is slightly
correlated,
especially when you correct for body
size and so his brain mass and so is
thickness of the Myelin Sheath.
So an individual neurons.
So there are these,
there's these micro markers of.
You might think about them as
neurological integrity that seemed to
predict Iq,
but you've been doing neuroimaging and
I'm not as up on that.
I haven't looked at that for a couple of
years,
so what have the neuro imagers found
about brain structure and function in
relationship to intelligence that you
think is compelling and interesting?
Glad you asked this because as I was
finishing the manuscript for the book,
literally
after I turned it in,
I had to ask for it back because there
was this very interesting study
published by a group at Yale that has,
that used a fairly sophisticated way to
look at white matter connection,
functional structural white matter
connections and functional connections
in the brain.
Um,
and determining how one brain area is
functionally or structuring structurally
related to all other brain areas.
And you can put up a map of,
of a person's brain that shows from
brain imaging,
from MRI technology,
how their brain is interconnected.
This paper said these inner connections
are so reliable within a person that
they're like fingerprints and not only
that,
but the fingerprints can predict Iq,
the density of connections,
density of interconnections or something
like that.
Or is there something more specific
going on?
It can be the density of connections
structurally.
How much white matter connects this area
to that area,
you know,
and there are certain brain areas where
you have a lot of white matter coming in
and a lot of white matter going out to
other parts of the brain that are called
hubs and there are nodes that have
lesser connections and so it makes it
certainly makes sense that being able to
make measurements of brain activity
would be related to things like
intelligence.
And
do you remember what some of the major
hubs we're like,
are they identifiable as also as
neuroanatomical areas with specific?
Yeah.
Countries definitely neuro,
no anatomical areas and they're white,
you might expect,
but they.
What was exciting to me is they mapped
on to a,
a,
a model of brain intelligence
relationships that I had developed with
my colleague rex young and published in
2007 and it was called the parietal
frontal integration theory of
intelligence.
And the idea is that the connections
between the parietal lobe,
which is here and the frontal area,
are the key connections for
intelligence.
Tell us,
tell us why you derive that particular
theory.
Because you know,
people have suggested say alternatively
that the seat of higher order
intelligence is basically let's say the
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex or
something like that.
So why specifically the connection,
the connection patterns between frontal
and Parietal area was.
Well,
this article in 2007 was a review
article where we took every single
imaging study we could find that
included a measure of intelligence and
there were 37 such studies at the time,
including some I had done as early as
1988 and others had done with much
larger samples and we just kinda
qualitatively analyze the results to see
what brain areas came up in common
across these studies using different
measures,
different imaging techniques.
And we found that there was not an that
not all brain areas were equally
distributed.
They tended to be concentrated in the
front and the parietal lobe,
but also we found areas in the occipital
lobe and the temporal lobe that were
also related to intelligence.
And so we developed this model that we
talked about how information would be
processed and how information would flow
around this set of.
I think there were 18 areas all
hypothesize,
scored high on intelligence tests would
have some combination of these areas.
You didn't need all of them kind of
working together,
but some people would have this
combination,
some people will have that combination
and if you can make measurements of
about the way information was flowing
around these areas with technology like
there may be ground which shows changes
in the brain millisecond by millisecond
that you might be able to actually
estimate Iq from Brighton images.
Two Thousand and seven people were
trying to do this with multiple
regression equations that never really
replicated.
Independent replications didn't go very
far because the sample sizes were
relatively small and you have enormous
individual differences,
but these newer techniques,
these mathematical techniques of
calculating brain conductivity really
seem to have advanced this whole thing.
Dramatic.
Was there a map between the nodes that
were identified in this more recent
research in the areas that you guys had
identified with your overarching
analysis?
Yes,
to to the way,
and I looked at the data.
It seemed like there was considerable
overlap and some of the authors who we
did not know personally when they wrote
their papers,
noted that the findings were consistent
with our model.
Any hemispheric differences?
We are,
yes,
there were.
There were more on the left than on the
right,
but there were also areas on the right
as well and these areas tend to be areas
that are also related to a language and
memory and attention.
More fundamental cognitive processes of
language,
memory and attention seem to be the the,
the architecture on which intelligence
you.
Here's a question that I haven't been
able to figure out because I've looked
at the attention literature lot and the
more I look at the attention literature,
the more I find it difficult to
distinguish it from the intelligence
literature.
I mean attention and intelligence seemed
to be different things and we certainly
use the words in common parlance as
different,
but I haven't really been able to like
imagine you wanted to establish a
battery of attention related tests that
were independent of Ge loaded a
cognitive abilities.
I haven't seen anybody manage that and
so do.
Do you,
what do you think the difference is
between the capacity to pay attention,
which also seems to be associated with
conscientiousness by the way,
which isn't associated with Iq,
but I mean what's the relationship
between intention,
attention and intelligence as far as
you're concerned,
so studies have been done where they
take cognitive variables,
elemental cognitive tasks is what they
call them,
the real basic things that cognitive
psychologists like to study,
like the study reasoning,
and they all studied wanting in memory,
but they don't want to address why some
people learn faster than other people or
why some people can remember more than
other people.
That's a cognitive psychologist study.
They studied what's common to everybody,
but if you look at these elemental
cognitive tasks so you can extracted a
Jew factor of cognition,
which is highly correlated with a
psychometric sure abilities more than
attention.
Memory aspects of memory are more
correlated to the gene factor.
A processing speed is correlated.
Sure,
and the tension is also correlated.
So I kind of have this idea from being a
parent watching my kids grow up,
that people differ in their baseline of
attention when they're not specifically
paying attention.
This might be called consciousness.
So you know,
you have two kids walking through a
museum for an hour and you come out and
you're saying the kid one.
So why did you see?
And you get a whole long thing and yes,
the other kid.
Well,
why did you see there?
And you'd get a much was rich
explanation.
Yeah.
Of what I've always thought about that
as a difference in resolution of worlds.
Well,
yeah,
call what you will,
but you know,
there are these differences.
And uh,
you know,
we have,
we've actually studied consciousness
with brain imaging,
uh,
with my friend Mike outlier who's an
anesthesiologist.
We did the first imaging studies where
we brought normal volunteers in and Mike
gave them a anesthetic drugs to knock
them out completely.
They underwent brain imaging and we had
different levels of anesthesia.
We were trying to see what part of the
brain is the last part of the brain to
turn off when you lose consciousness.
And they're than
did you find anything that you can make
sense out of from that?
Because of course,
that's obviously an extraordinarily
interesting question.
Immediately the collapse of these
networks is
just the real expert on the whole series
of papers that the mechanism of
consciousness is still one of the Great
Nobel prize winning.
Yeah.
Well,
that's my interpretation of literature
too.
It's like,
it,
it's,
it's such a mystery that it seems
uncrackable in some sense.
Well,
what was good about the imaging stuff?
You could study this experimentally.
Yep.
You know,
you could,
you could put people into different
levels of consciousness and burning them
out at will and seeing what,
how the brain reacted.
So the Thalamus seems to be an
important.
A lot of people.
And I found those connections,
uh,
and each anesthetic,
there are categories of anesthetics and
they weren't.
They have different mechanisms of action
in the brain,
yet they all produce the same a
consequence when you purchased this,
that's a very interesting thing to.
So what does it,
cortical thalamic loops will mean.
There's a guy named,
what's his name?
God,
it's close to that.
I'm afraid to.
I haven't gotten it right.
He suggests that I'm one of the,
one of the consequences of psychedelic
drugs is to decrease the gating of the
thalamic cortical circuitry and,
and that that's one of the mechanisms
whereby that expanded at least sense of
consciousness emerges as a constantly,
you know,
as a,
as a consequence of experimentation with
this,
with the psychedelic end of the
pharmaceutical universe.
Yeah.
We have a section where I talk about
consciousness studies and try to relate
the concept that if you can turn
consciousness off,
you should be able to turn it on.
No anesthesiologists do this at will eop
even though they don't understand what
they're doing.
Right,
right.
You know,
uh,
they,
they can't tell you why it works.
But then can you use if,
if anesthetic drugs had to dissociate
the brain and creativity seems to be
related to a dissociation of the frontal
lobes can lower doses,
very,
very low doses of anesthetic drugs
caused just enough dis inhibition to
increase your creativity.
And I don't think this experiment has
ever been done.
No.
You see something similar in that
sometimes reported with people who've
developed frontal temporal dementia at.
Exactly.
Right.
And that's,
that's,
that's a very strange phenomenon where
as your brain deteriorates,
your creativity increases because so
much of brain function seems to be
inhibitory.
So I don't know if a comparable disease
that produces increases in intelligence,
right?
No,
no,
I've never heard of that.
Oh yeah.
The other thing that's been,
so,
you tell me what you think about this.
I mean,
I was curious for awhile about these
companies like lumosity,
because when we developed our original
prefrontal tap tasks,
they weren't tests.
They were,
they kind of had a game like element,
you know,
and we kind of thought,
well maybe if you have people practice
doing them,
um,
they would obviously get better at the
specific task because that is what
people do.
But then if you had people practice a
whole bunch of them,
maybe they would get better at the
whole,
at the entirety of the tasks in a way
that would generalize to other,
to other measures like the Raven's
progressive matrices,
which is a good measure of fluid
intelligence.
But that never works,
and of course the lumosity people
claimed that they were able to produce
enhancement in general intelligence,
but by all appearances,
appearances,
that's been a.
that's been a dismal failure as well.
It's,
it's,
it's very strange in some sense that
that general factor doesn't seem to be
something that you can actually improve
by practice.
Not What the hell why?
Why can't.
I just don't get that.
It doesn't make sense.
But
here's something you don't know about
me.
I'll bet.
But I am in the Guinness Book of Records
to Gamers addition because of my study,
my brain imaging study of Tetris and I
did a brain imaging study of Tetris.
I thought it was published in 1992.
I really want to do a study of warning.
I wanted to see what happened in the
brain before and after your one
something.
And back in 1991 when I was doing this,
nobody had personal computers.
Nobody had ever heard of tattooist
computer games were not what they are
today.
And I went to the egghead software store
when they had software stores that had
just opened and I was talking to the
guys there about I needed something
where I could study before and after
they learned something relatively
simple.
Yep.
They showed me this game,
tetris.
It had just come in.
They just had opened the box.
They put it up on the computer there and
I thought,
boy,
this is really perfect.
It's simple to learn,
but there's an enormous learning curve.
And we.
We brought in a college students,
a small number of college students,
and we showed them how to play tetris.
They practice for a few minutes.
We injected the radioactive glucose for
positron emission tomography and we did
a pet scan studies of them that very
first day played tetris for 32 minutes.
They've been practiced everyday.
They had to come to my office because
nobody had a pc at home.
They came to my office five days a week
for about four weeks.
They practice until they got so good at
Tetris.
Game is moving faster.
It's amazing how good people can get it.
You couldn't even believe a human being
could do.
I've watched people do that sort of
thing.
It's just absolutely unbelievable how
good they can get out of it and when
they got really good,
we scanned on the second time and we
found that even though the game was
faster,
harder,
when they had learned how to do it,
they used less glucose metabolic rate.
Okay,
so now I knew that research.
I read that research.
Now.
What do you think about?
The problem is,
I can't remember where this research
came from because I also read at
approximately the same time studies that
appeared to claim and I think this was
reviewed by Al Conan Goldberg and his
book on a on hemispheric specialization
for regionalization and novelty
respectively.
That as you,
when you first start to learn something
novel,
and I think this was demonstrated,
for example,
in people who are listening,
they were Danish native speakers who are
listening to Danish in reverse and they
use very large part portions of their
brain when they were listening to Davish
and reverse,
but if they were listening to Danish
property spoken,
they use very small specified parts of
the brain that were located in the
ladder or enough in the back part of the
left hemisphere and there was another
group of researchers who were
demonstrating that as you learned,
the degree of activation decreased and
it shifted from the right to the left
and it shifted from the front to the
back and it got smaller and smaller.
And is that associated with that
decreased glucose utilization?
Is that the same phenomena?
I think it is
to show it.
We had done one,
one imaging study before this tetris
study where we'll just correlated a
glucose metabolic rate with scores on a
test of abstract reasoning.
The hygiene load tests.
They had taken the test during the
imaging,
so we'll see what brain areas we're
involved and we did find some brain
areas,
but the really interesting,
surprising thing was the correlation
between the scores and glucose metabolic
rate was always negative other than they
did on the test,
the lower their glucose metabolic rate,
and that was the first thing we had
about this idea of brain efficiency that
there's been a lot of research on that
turns out to be a complicated thing
because nothing about the brain is
simple,
right?
But it
does seem to make perfect sense that
expert skill is associated with doing
more with less.
It makes sense now,
but I tell you,
nobody predicted it.
And look,
I understand.
All right,
that's research that research stood out
for me in a very,
very,
uh,
you know,
in a,
in a very striking manner.
So this thing about that you raised
about practicing on different kinds of
tests because of the attractive things
about tetricks is visual spacial
planning ahead to pension.
There are a lot of elemental cognitive
tasks necessary.
You know,
it was fine motor control,
really necessary to do well on tech
person to run it really well.
And so the Tetris company found my
research some years later and asked if
I'd be willing to try to replicate it
with more modern imaging,
which of course I was willing to do.
So they funded this and um,
we found now instead of pet scanning,
we use functional Mri and structural Mri
both.
And we did find,
we found with the pet scanning for areas
where after a teenage girls with very
limited gaming experience Tetris,
their brain activity decreased.
But we also found from the structural
MRI that there were increases in gray
matter.
And the really interesting thing is the
areas where there were increases in gray
matter did not overlap at all with the
areas that functionally decreased.
It would have been a terrific story that
strange things are always more
complicated than you hope them to be.
Not only that,
but I can tell you that every time I did
a brain imaging study,
we always found the exact opposite of
what we expected.
That,
that sounds to me like,
you know,
you might actually be,
be,
uh,
be operating as a real scientist.
What does,
I mean things are so damn complicated
that it's really difficult to guess,
right?
To begin with.
Well,
I went to one of my three laws based on
one.
Number one is no story about the brain
is simple.
One,
number two is no one study is definitive
and law number three is it takes a long
time to sort out all the various studies
to see what's consistent and what
establishes a reliable way to have
evidence.
Let me put you on a different track
momentarily and maybe this won't work
but,
but you know,
I'm always curious about,
uh,
let's say the practical implications of
scientific research both at a personal
level,
familiar level,
social level,
all of those things.
You know.
So I mean,
one of the things that I'm planning to
do in the near future is to launch a
website where that will enable people to
assess themselves with what we've
developed a scale called the big five
aspect scale that breaks the big five
down into 10 aspects,
each of which,
which provides some additional high
resolution and useful descriptions of
personality.
So you'll be able to go there and find
out what your personality is like.
You'd be able to compare yourself to
other people who,
you know,
to find out where your similarities and
differences are.
But one of the things we've been
thinking about doing as well is putting
up on the same side or real Iq tests
nicely validated,
probably focusing on fluid intelligence
because it's a little bit less
linguistically complex to do so,
but maybe measuring verbal intelligence
and then showing people the strata of
occupations in which they're likely to
find maximal success.
Because you know from,
for me,
given that I know that,
that people vary in their cognitive
abilities tremendously and that that's
actually an important determinant of
their life outcome.
It seems to me.
So let's say someone tests out in an Iq
of around 150,
and so you can say,
look,
you know,
you're pretty damn smart.
You're,
you're up above 85 percent of the
general population.
You could,
you could probably do a pretty damn good
job as an undergraduate in university if
you're also disciplined,
right?
If you were conscientious,
he hit the books harder.
You're gonna,
you're gonna come out in the top core
tile of your class,
assuming that you're not at a
spectacularly successful,
a spectacularly selective university,
but you're going to have a much more
difficult time as a master's student and
phd level stuff is going to be.
You're going to be pushing your luck to
really master that.
But you know,
you could be,
here's a,
here's a domain of,
of,
uh,
what would you call it?
Industrial organizational activity where
you could really be in the top 10
percentile.
You know,
it's like.
So if you have an Iq of 115,
like you might make one bang up plumber
and you could have a spectacularly
successful career as a plumber.
And maybe as a manager of other plumbers
and all of that and you know,
and I,
I actually happened to be a real
efficacy and of the trade,
so I certainly don't think of that as
something that's a,
that's a low quality or low status
occupation in the least.
But we would,
we would like to tell people,
okay heres,
heres,
here's a,
here's an intellectual domain that's
probably too high for you to be
successful without working insane hours
to,
to close the gap because you can do that
within st work up to some,
some limited degree.
But it seems to me that the logical
thing to do at least in part is to give
people a sense of what their advantages
and limitations are and then say to
them,
okay,
well given that here's a place that you
could go where you could be optimally
successful.
And so,
you know,
that's Kinda my take from a policy
perspective let's say.
But like what have you thought about,
you know,
the massive diversity and intellectual
ability.
You mean what are the implications from
a policy perspective as far as you're
concerned or location or guidance is
clearly one.
I actually did some consulting and some
research for a nonprofit group called
the Johnson O'connor Foundation,
which is a vocational testing.
We're not that big on ge,
but they have their own battery of
tests.
They bring someone in and do a full day
of,
of cognitive tests.
And from that they give some advice
about what kinds of professions match
their cognitive strengths and
weaknesses.
And I actually did some brain imaging,
uh,
on their tests and it was very,
very interesting stuff.
Um,
because it's hard to do the
psychometrics properly with regards to
vocational guidance because we don't
really know.
We don't have a good handle on how to
classify jobs into their various
subtypes.
Like John Holland has done some good
work doing that,
but,
but there's so many jobs and it's hard
to figure out,
well,
what makes two jobs the same or similar,
you know?
No,
I was at Hopkins when Holland was there
in some of my friends were graduate
students work for him.
And I learned all about that vocational
testing.
That's very powerful.
And as you know,
it's,
that's more of his,
his scales have kind of morphed into
more personality.
White dementia.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's exactly the nexus that we want to
play out.
It's like,
okay,
because there is a reason.
I know people have been mapping Holland
Holland job categories onto the big five
and we have a fair bit of success,
you know,
and we're hoping that the
differentiation down to the 10 levels of
personality will provide even more
precision.
But,
but with more general policy let.
Okay.
So far,
so reasonable vocational counseling.
That's a good idea.
When does it start?
Does it start in junior high?
Like do you do
the Europeans do and start to attract
people into trades and,
and,
and higher education at that early age.
European seemed to have had great
success with that.
So it's certainly Germans in particular.
Yeah.
So reasonable to look at.
But the problem in the United States,
there were so many problems with the way
we conceptualize education and the whole
idea of tracking.
I don't know how it is in Canada,
but in the United States,
this idea of tracking has a very
negative valance.
Do it,
you know,
segregating the smart kids into one,
one a set of classes and the less smart
kids in dollars and then there's
remedial education and,
and there's been a tendency,
a strong tendency in the United States
to feel that kids learn from each other.
So you don't want homogeneous groups
based on learning ability.
Your want.
Yeah.
It's so funny because people say that
with regards to two,
let's say academic achievement,
but they play exactly the opposite.
Stumped when it comes to such things as
has childhood sports,
you know,
so if you look at football for example,
it's like,
well hey,
let's segregate like abilities.
Like you don't have the people who
stumble around on the field,
dropping the ball all the time,
playing the top end quarterbacks and
nobody thinks there's a problem with
that.
They don't say,
well,
everyone learns from everyone else in
that situation.
So to me it speaks more of a refusal to
admit to the stark reality that there
are massive cognitive differences
between people.
And to try to actually start to address
that with some degree of seriousness and
the serious should be something like,
okay,
well let's look at the bottom 15 percent
of the population cognitively speaking.
It's like,
what the hell can we do for those people
that's going to be useful and you know,
like the guy that I was telling you
about,
I was trying to think of some way that
he could find a respectable and
productive and relatively stable
position in society that would be
useful.
And I thought there was a couple of
things he could do.
Like one of the things he could've done,
I think he could have been encouraged,
let's say,
to,
to collect trash in the downtown areas.
Like he could have been assigned a city
block and it could have been said to
him,
look,
your job is to keep this damn city block
clean.
Here's the bag,
here's the stick.
You get up in the morning,
you go do this.
It's like it makes everybody's life more
pleasant.
It's a valuable contribution.
It's something you could do with a
certain degree of pride and it.
And there's a socially valuable end of
it.
Now what happens in Toronto is that
people drive around these vacuum cleaner
machines on sidewalks and pick up the
scrap paper and all of that.
That actually turns out to be a very
cognitively demanding job because,
well,
you have to pay careful attention.
You can't run over people.
You have to have decent social skills.
And you know,
it's complicated.
But it might be nice to see.
But we were not mature enough to have a
discussion like this as a society we
might want to say is like,
okay,
well there's a group of people who
aren't going to be able to compete in
the,
in the cognitive workplace.
They're not going to do it.
And there's actually lots of them and
we're not going to say they're lazy and
we're not going to say they're not
looking for work.
We're not going to say any of that.
We're going to say,
look,
we need to find occupations that have
public utility that aren't just make
work projects that people have.
That level of abstract capacity could
actually perform.
But I don't think we have the maturity
to have that conversation.
We don't have the economics.
And so I would go even a little to the
left of you and I would say there's
nothing wrong with make work programs,
you know,
to,
to allow people.
I mean,
you have to work with dignity.
So you heard that option,
but you also have this interesting
experiment being proposed of the minimum
annual income.
Yeah.
Well that worries me because see if
there's a couple of things about that
when it concerns me because,
you know,
so we're having a conversation here
where we're taking,
um,
differences in Iq seriously.
But the problem with a guaranteed annual
income issue,
I think one of the problems,
and I'm not denying its potential
utility,
it's something that I think that would
have to be experimentally determined and
all of that.
And maybe it could replace a plethora of
less efficient social welfare programs.
But,
you know,
it isn't obvious to me.
It's obvious to me that there's a
substantial proportion of the
population.
And I would say it's probably five
percent that would destroy themselves
instantly if you gave them a guaranteed
annual income and they would do it
because they're very low in
conscientiousness,
for example,
and very impulsive and like I've worked
with many guys,
often x cocaine addicts who were often
not all that high on the end of the
cognitive distribution,
but very,
very low in conscientiousness,
high and impulsivity.
And those guys were absolutely fine as
long as they were flat broke.
But man,
I tell you as soon as they had money,
they were done.
It was like three days in the bar,
cocaine binge face down in a ditch and
then they were fine until they got money
again.
And so I don't.
The problem with the garden teed annual
income solution is that man does not
live by bread alone,
let's say.
And that if you have money and you have
things to do,
then you have a life.
But if you just have money,
you don't have a life.
I'm looking at,
you know,
I have a very narrow lens on this.
What do I know about the big social
policies?
And No,
I don't know anything about that more
than anybody else.
I have opinions like everybody,
but my narrow lens is through
intelligence.
Yep.
I think more is better than.
Less.
More doesn't make you a better person,
doesn't make you honest,
doesn't make you likable,
doesn't make your conscience does.
It,
doesn't solve the problems of the world.
But if we can do something to increase
intelligence,
generally I think that would go in some
measure toward alleviating a lot of
these,
uh,
very complex problems.
So I'm managing the homelessness
problem.
Some proportion of chronically homeless
people have schizophrenia.
Schizophrenia is a genetic disorder.
Nobody knows what the genes are or how
they work,
but it's pretty clear there's a genetic
component.
If you can find the genes,
figure out what they do and come up with
real good treatments.
If chores for schizophrenia and possibly
preventions for schizophrenia,
that indirectly is going to help
alleviate the homeless problem.
Right?
So I don't know what to do about the
homeless,
but if you can figure out what to do
about schizophrenia,
that's going to have some impact on
that.
Yes.
It's basically,
yeah,
we'll use your claim to some degree is
that these more complex social problems
should be into isolative or micro
problems and that specific solution
should be sought for them and now that
certainly strikes
me as an appropriate approach because
everybody is different.
Not everyone's the same reason.
No,
no.
Well that's for sure.
That's for sure.
Not everyone's poor for the same route,
for the same reason,
by any stretch of the imagination.
That's right.
Poverty is.
Doesn't have one cause no,
not nearly caused by lack of money
either because that would be a much
easier problem to solve unfortunately.
It's not so simple.
So the one thing that we're probably
getting towards the end,
the one thing I would like to leave your
listeners with is really optimism.
Not Dismal problems in perpetuity
because the genetic approach,
I think,
and I'm kind of out,
you know,
I'm kind of out there on this.
This is not a mainstream view,
but I think the more something is
genetic,
the more lives we can change it and
that's why we should study the genetics
of intelligence.
That's why I hope genes have more to do
with it,
that environment,
not,
no,
not yet because I want to do something
nefarious with jeeps and I understand
the history of this varies because I
think in neuroscience there's,
there's optimism and to guard against
the negative aspects,
the potential negative aspects of this.
The only solution is to have public
conversation about this and we get
people to understand Iq,
intelligence,
g factor,
these are not all the same things.
They have different relationships to the
data,
the genetic data particularly.
So we have to understand these things
and once we have some sense of this and
not paint people who believe in that
there's a genetic component is as our,
as our a priori racists or malevolent
people.
Um,
I think we,
we,
we can come to a common understanding
about how genes and environment interact
and figure out how all that works and
begin to think how in the year 20,
50,
or 20,
60 are going to help them resolve,
resolve some of these issues to
practical benefit.
Well that is a good place.
We've had a very productive discussion.
So I think that's probably a nice place
to,
to bring everything to a close.
I'd been speaking with Dr Richard Hire
who studies the neuro basis of human
intelligence and cognition and who has
recently released a new book called and
real science of intelligence published
by Cambridge University press.
It's an academic book,
but for people who are interested in a
serious discussion of the relationship
between biology and intelligence,
then it's a good Goto Tome and,
uh,
it's,
it's an extraordinarily important topic
given the undeniable primacy of
intelligence as the fundamental
predictor of,
of,
of let's say,
success in many,
many domains in,
in,
across the human lifespan.
So thank you very much for spending an
hour or so with us today.
And,
uh,
and with any luck,
maybe we'll talk to you again in the
future.
I'd like to talk to you perhaps about
consciousness at some point that might
be entertaining.
Well,
I've listened to.
I've really enjoyed it.
I appreciate the chance of family more
than three sentences.
Three sentences are related to your
listeners.
I just want to say one thing about the
book.
It is written for the lay public as
well.
That's a good thing to know.
Cambridge wouldn't let me call it the
neuroscience of intelligence called what
every parent and student needs to know
about the neuro science,
but because they wanted to market it as
a strictly academic God,
but I.
it's getting quite a bit of attention.
Just a moment.
Nonacademic.
Excellent.
Well,
I'll,
I'll make sure that I.
I mentioned that in the description
which I will.
I'll post the link to the book probably
on Amazon.
That's usually the most straightforward
thing and also point out that it is in
fact written for people who aren't only
specialists in the area.
That was good.
Thanks.
Thanks a lot.
Hey listen,
thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
No problem.
It's a pleasure talking with you too.
Good to meet you.